je suis musicien joue de la musique
c'est ce que je sais faire le mieux
il vit depuis cape le jazz américain à
paris c'est moi le king of swing go
c'est qui ce clown parce qu'il est nos
salles au stage comme latine se présente
pas en dépression ajoute c'est notre
docteur jazz connu ce que vous voir
jouer vers l'avant j'irai pas si on perd
là plus de docteurs jazz on est mort un
cas leur dire django veux le même cachet
que plaque gabol merci beaucoup
d'arrestations de tziganes messi ne
brise pas il sera battu sauvagement
[Musique]
c'est pas ma guerre ça
tut à fuir ce qui prépare dans l'ombre
et abominable
[Musique]
quand un musicien unique elle pas encore
composé de très belles choses
oubliez le
[Musique]
il écoute comme sais pas
fais tout moi que je partis qui devait
nous faire passer en juin
tu là avec ma famille à attendre un
signal pour passer s'est jamais le bon
moment
j'y crois plus à vos promesses
six autres touristes de tous
[Musique]
on connaissait la musique en moi
le caennais